- [Kim] Hey, this is
Kim from Khan Academy,
and today I'm talking with some experts
about The Fourth Amendment.
This is the Fourth Amendment
of the Bill of Rights,
and the Fourth Amendment
deals with unreasonable search
and seizure.
So here's the official
text of the amendment.
It says, "This right of
the people to be secure
"in their persons, houses,
papers, and effects,
"against unreasonable
searches and seizures,
"shall not be violated, and
no Warrants shall issue,
"but upon probable cause,
supported by Oath or affirmation,
"and particularly describing
the place to be searched,
"and the persons or things to be seized."
To learn more about the
the Fourth Amendment,
I talked to two law professors
who specialize in criminal law,
Professor Tracey Meares of Yale University
and Professor Orin Kerr of
George Washington University,
and he's a particular
expert in criminal procedure
and computer crime.
Professor Kerr, can you
tell us a little bit about
what the Fourth Amendment
is and why the Framers
were interested in protecting
these rights in particular?
- [Orin] The Fourth Amendment is a ban
on unreasonable searches and
seizures by the government.
It's something the
Framers were interested in
because they wanted to limit
the government's power.
At the time of the framing,
the English King had engaged
in some pretty bad things
that the Framers wanted to stop,
and one of those was
raiding people's homes
with what was called a general warrant.
A general warrant was
basically a warrant that said
the police could go anywhere
and look for anything
without any limit.
- [Kim] I asked Professor
Meares to explain
a little bit more about general warrants.
She's a professor at Yale Law School
who specializes in criminal procedure
and criminal law policy.
- [Tracey] They were a general warrant
allowing these officials
to search people's homes,
places, papers, the kinds of things
that the Fourth Amendment lists
in ways that people thought
was not okay.
The Fourth Amendment
was primarily concerned
with a couple of things.
One: a case involving a
seditious libel investigation.
It's a case called Entick.
And a warrant was issued
authorizing Entick,
that's the subject of
the warrant, his arrest,
and the seizure of all
of his books and papers
so that he could be prosecuted
for seditious libel.
That case isn't as well-known
as the second case,
which is called the
Writs of Assistance case,
and basically, the Writs
of Assistance involved
customs inspectors who
were trying to crack down
on smuggling that was
affecting Boston's economy,
so to add in that task, inspectors
used writs of assistance
that were issued by the king
and authorized the inspectors
both to draft assistance,
hence the name "writs of assistance,"
and to search any place
where smuggled goods
might be concealed.
- [Orin] The Framers wanted
to put an end to that
and so they said, "No general
warrants are allowed,"
and searches and seizures
have to be reasonable.
That really means is the
government can't just stop anyone,
arrest anyone, break into someone's house.
There are limits as to
what the government can do.
- [Kim] But what are those limits?
What determines probable
cause for a search
and what renders a search
and seizure unreasonable?
- [Orin] Yeah, what counts as unreasonable
is a really big question.
There are different answers
different courts have suggested,
but the basic idea is that
first if the government
has a valid warrant, a search
or a seizure is reasonable.
If the warrant, if a judge
has signed off and said,
"Yeah, the government has probable cause
"to search this place
for particular evidence,"
then the government can do that.
And then the Supreme Court has laid out
a bunch of what they call exceptions
to the warrant requirement,
which are also reasonable searches.
So for example, if a person
consents to a search,
that's reasonable.
Or in the case of a car,
a car can be searched without a warrant
based on probable cause.
That's called the automobile exception.
There are rules that govern
when the police can stop
somebody temporarily.
When the government needs an arrest,
they need probable cause.
There are basically all sorts of rules
that the Supreme Court has laid out
on a bunch of different cases
that say what counts as an
unreasonable search or seizure.
The Supreme Court has
said that probable cause
means a fair probability
that evidence will be found
in a particular place or
that a particular person
committed a crime, and "fair
probability" is the language,
but that's not something
the Supreme Court has said.
You know, that's not 50%.
That doesn't mean it's
more probable than not.
It just means that there's
pretty good reason to think
that there's evidence to
be in a particular place
or that a particular
person committed a crime.
So it doesn't mean a hunch,
it doesn't mean the officer
just had the idea pop into his head,
but it also doesn't mean
that the officer's certain.
There's just got to be
a pretty good reason,
but not certainty,
to think that that
person committed a crime
or there's evidence there.
- [Kim] But when I asked Professor
Meares the same question,
she wasn't convinced
it was so easy to tell
what counts as probable cause.
So what counts as a true probable cause
to issue a warrant upon?
(Tracey sighs)
(Kim laughs) Sorry.
We can just skip this instead.
- [Tracey] Let's take a second.
I mean, I taught this today.
You can't, these aren't questions
that you can just simply answer.
No one can actually.
I mean, there is, I mean
literally, I taught today
the fact that there is no real law
on what probable cause is.
It's inherently a factual determination.
- [Kim] So how does this work in practice?
I asked Professor Kerr
if it's the case that
a police officer has to convince a judge
that there's probable
cause to issue a warrant.
- [Orin] Yes, that can
come up in two ways.
In some cases, the Supreme Court says
the police have to go to a
judge first and get a warrant
and then they have to convince the judge
that what they're about to do
is based on probable cause.
And other cases come up
when the government has
searched first or arrested first
and then they come back with the evidence
or come back with the
person who was arrested
and then there's a hearing as to whether
there was probable cause for the arrest
that already occurred,
so either way the standards are the same.
It's that fair probability idea,
ultimately up to a judge
whether the police were right
or wrong in doing what they did.
- [Kim] Interesting, so
there is a little bit of
prior legwork involved in some cases.
What happens in cases when
it might be really important
to get evidence, say if
there's a bomb threat?
- [Orin] So there are some
rules that allow searches
or seizures without a warrant
under what they call
exigent circumstances.
That basically means
there is an emergency,
so the government had to act
without a search warrant.
And so if there is a ticking time bomb
that they think is gonna
go off in a package
and they've got good reason to think
there is this ticking
time bomb in the package,
they don't have to say, "Hey,
we're gonna go find a judge,"
because by the time they do that,
the bomb might have gone off.
They can search that package
under this exigent circumstances idea.
So that's an exception to the
rules, although beyond that,
there is no difference
between a serious case
and a less serious case
under the Fourth Amendment.
They're kind of all serious cases,
so the courts have to follow
and the police have to follow
the same rules in less serious
and more serious cases.
- [Kim] Professor Meares
gave me an example
of what seemed like a less serious case,
but it's still a really
interesting example
of what counts as an
unreasonable search and seizure.
- [Tracey] I'll give you one more case
that I'm sure the high
school students will love,
and my students love it.
It's a case where a person
was sitting in a noddle shop
in front of a window eating
a big bowl of noodles,
clear soup with noodles, and
a police officer walks by
the person eating the noddles
and notices something floating
in the bowl of noodles.
So he enters into the store
where the person is eating the noodles
and the person has left
temporarily the bowl of noodles
to get a napkin or go to
the bathroom or something.
And then the police officer
approaches the bowl,
picks up the person's
spoon and stirs the noodles
to see if he can find anything
and some baggies of
crack float to the top.
Did the person have a reasonable
expectation of privacy
in their food?
- [Kim] In their soup?
- [Tracey] In their soup.
(Kim laughs)
- [Kim] How did they rule?
- [Tracey] They ruled that
the stirring was a search.
So if it is a search, and i.e.,
that you have a subjective
interest of privacy
in your soup that society is prepared to
recognize as reasonable,
then the police officer would
have to get a warrant
before stirring the soup.
- [Kim] This raises the question.
Where I have Fourth Amendment rights?
Are some locations
protected and not others?
- [Orin] The building block
of the Fourth Amendment
is really that you have
Fourth Amendment rights
in your home, in your
pockets, in your packages,
but you don't have Fourth
Amendment rights outside.
You don't have Fourth Amendment rights
in what you're doing outside
or if the police want to walk
on what they call open
fields, public streets,
that, you don't have Fourth
Amendment rights in that.
So thinking about how the
Fourth Amendment applies
just in the physical world,
if the police want to
break into your home,
they need a search warrant.
If the police want to watch
you walk down the street,
they don't need anything.
It's not a search or a seizure,
so they can do anything they
want, just watching you.
If they want to arrest you,
they need probable cause
to believe you've committed a crime.
So those are really the building blocks
of the Fourth Amendment
going back to 18th-century technology.
And then the big question becomes,
"All right. Well, how do you
update that to a modern world?"
- [Tracey] It's also the case
that the Fourth Amendment
applies to seizures,
so what police have to show
before they arrest a person
or temporarily stop them,
or briefly pat their body
on the outside of their body for weapons.
All of those questions are
Fourth Amendment questions,
as are questions involving how much force
police actually use to effect the arrest
once we've decided that
an arrest is legitimate.
So we haven't talked about
any of those questions
but the Fourth Amendment
governs all of that
and remember,
the Fourth Amendment
governs all of those topics
in a context in which
the Framers' motivations
for enacting the Fourth Amendment
have absolutely nothing to do
with most of those
things I just mentioned.
- [Kim] But the Fourth
Amendment also has implications
that go beyond warrants and seizures.
Professor Meares thinks that one of the
biggest Fourth Amendment
issues today is discretion.
- [Tracey] Many people have
thought much more about
how the Fourth Amendment protects privacy
than how the Fourth Amendment
addresses discretion.
- [Kim] And by discretion
in this case, you mean
what they get to decide
to do on their own, right?
- [Tracey] Exactly so.
And one way to see the difference
between those two things
is to think about a metal
detector in an airport.
So long as everyone is
required to go through
the metal detector,
there is no law enforcement
discretion involved.
- [Kim] So this is kind of
where the public safety aspect
comes in, that if we're all subject to
non-invasive procedures
at the whim of police,
it's a little different
than if individuals
are kind of plucked for that reason?
- [Tracey] Right, that
it's just pointing out
that targeting,
the targeting of people for
invasions is a different problem
than the invasion problem itself, right?
And so if all we ever do is
think about privacy invasion
without thinking about
the discretion problem,
then we're missing something important.
- [Kim] For Professor Kerr however,
the most important issue at stake today
regarding the Fourth
Amendment is how it will apply
to electronic media.
- [Orin] Well, the big question I think
is how the Fourth Amendment is gonna apply
to searches and seizures
of computers, of emails,
to the internet, new technologies
that we all use every day.
We wake up in the morning and hop online
or go on Twitter or
whatever you use online,
lots and lots of communications
online all around the world,
and how does the Fourth
Amendment apply to that
is something that the courts
are beginning to answer
but they've only started to answer.
Some really, really hard
questions of kind of translating
that physical world concept
of the Fourth Amendment
to the world of computers
that we live today.
- [Kim] So, as we've learned,
the Fourth Amendment ensures
that government authorities
can't raid homes, pockets,
or papers without a
warrant issued by a judge,
and then only if there is a probable cause
to believe there is a reason for a search.
What's tricky is deciding
what counts as probable cause
and whether it's discriminatory to select
some people to search, but not others.
And how do we translate
the Fourth Amendment
to a world where our
papers are all digital?
Should the police be permitted
to search our cell phones,
our browsing histories, our
private social media profiles?
You can learn more about
the Fourth Amendment
by checking out the National
Constitution Center's
interactive Constitution,
and Khan Academy's resources
on US government and politics.